i mean the dress i mean what kind of
action hello how did you choose this one
you know um i just wanted to put floral
i wanted to invite spring early i've
been cold lately so it's just like let's
let's bloom you know we're asking
everybody what is one secret about your
look or getting ready process tonight i
always have to have turnip music
i'm not gonna lie i was feeling very
sleepy i went out to celebrate a
friend's birthday party so i was like
i'm just gonna do a little shot to wake
up and it worked
shot
okay and what was the turn up song of
choice um we started off with um nba
young boy
can't remember the song but
it did the job did the job i wish i had
a shot of vodka for you now yeah i wish
you there too come on
step it up yeah well it's a big night
multiple nominations how does it feel to
be here and recognized by the critics
choice
i'm really excited to be here it feels
like we're kind of back and
you know this is our last season to be
celebrated in this way and to be honored
is you know we're i'm just happy to be
here let's talk about you are presenting
miss halle berry i sure am i'm
presenting the queen tonight and i'm so
honored to present her like that has to
be because we all grow up watching her
like what what is a what is this moment
to be presenting halle berry with the
see her award you know hallie is a
legend she's an inspiration
seeing her win the oscar i remember
exactly where i was i remember you know
seeing her receive it with denzel i just
read her letter to sidney poitier and
that you know was so touching and so i'm
just
i
she paved the way for so many of us i'm
here because she's here so i love her do
you have a date tonight are we rocking
it
um i have you know a couple dates
and you're doing spiderman right i um i
don't know if i'm allowed to say
that but you love spiderman and i would
love to be doing it if i were
you